JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Hello, everyone.
How's it going?
Welcome to the machine
learning session at GCP Next.
Thanks for coming.
This session is all about
how you as developers
can add elements of intelligence
to your own applications.
I like to think of
it as a superpower,
because the capabilities
of machine learning far
outstripped what any one
of us can do on our own.
My name is Julia Ferraioli.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud Platform.
Back in the day, I did some
machine learning research,
but it's been awhile.
I know just enough
to be dangerous.
Later, I'll be joined
by David from Wix.com,
who will talk about
their experiences
with Google Cloud platform's
machine learning capabilities.
Now I suspect that the machine
learning plus Google story
makes a lot of sense
to many of you.
It's right there in
the mission statement,
to organize the
world's information.
And information is just
another way of saying data,
and data is oxygen
for machine learning.
Anything that you
do with your system
can be considered data,
whether it be logs,
behavior, uploads, et cetera.
And that data is
something that you
can get greater insight from.
How you use that
data and how you
extract knowledge
and understanding
can determine the
degree of your success.
So what is machine learning?
Who here is an expert
in machine learning?
Yeah, OK.
There are a few of you.
Excellent.
I am not one of them.
It's been the domain of the few.
You needed a Ph.D.
to dig into it,
and you needed to dig into
it to make use of it at all.
But understanding
the machine learning
concepts doesn't
require a Ph.D. You
can think of it as
taking data, running it
through an algorithm, to
yield some sort of insight.
That's it.
The more data you
have, the better.
And of course, you need
some place to store the data
and run the algorithm.
So infrastructure
is an integral part
of a machine learning system.
Over the years, we've had
to solve new problems.
And oftentimes, we've made use
of machine learning techniques
to do this.
So let's take a
brief look at how
we use machine learning Google.
I'm going to take two examples.
Who here uses Google Photos?
So not terribly long ago,
we added the capability
to search through your photos,
not using when it was taken
or where it was taken
or anything that you
can find in the EXIF data.
But we added the
capability to search
within the photos themselves.
So if you look for
photos of flowers,
you'll be able to get returned
photos that contain flowers.
And this comes from an
application of machine learning
that actually attempts to
comprehend what is going on
in the pixels themselves.
What story does it tell?
Google Translate
is a great example
of an application that's built
almost entirely on machine
learning.
It's powered by an
area of research
called machine translation.
And we build up a
statistical language model
so that lets us translate
from one language to another.
So you can get all of your
translation questions answered,
like how to say there are
too many pictures of cats
on the internet in Italian.
I'm going to use that when
I go to Italy, I'm sure.
So what can we as developers
do with machine learning?
You're hearing a lot about
it, especially yesterday
and again since
you're here today.
Well I like to think
of it as a spectrum.
Now on the left hand side
here, we have TensorFlow.
Who here has played
around with TensorFlow?
A few of you.
So TensorFlow is meant
primarily for researchers,
or folks in academia.
It needs more background,
more understanding of machine
learning and machine
learning techniques,
and it means you're going
to be writing more code.
Now on the right hand side, we
have the machine learning APIs.
Now, these let you access
fully trained models
that we've developed
as a service.
It's meant for people
building applications.
Cloud machine
learning, which is what
you heard about in
the keynote yesterday,
is kind of the middle and
it extends to either side.
It lets you get
hands-on building
and training your own
models using your own data.
And since it's an integral
part of Google Cloud Platform,
it also gives you easy access
to other cloud services,
like storage and
BigQuery and data flow.
So let's take a brief
look at TensorFlow
to give you a little bit of a
basis of understanding there.
So it was released
last year by Google,
the folks at Google Research.
And it's an open-source
machine learning library.
So right now, it's one of the
most popular machine learning
libraries on GitHub by
forks and stars et cetera.
And it's meant for
numerical computation.
What we're seeing people do
is use it in-- the most part,
for deep learning.
And deep learning is
an area of research
that attempts to answer
problems that we always
thought you needed human
intelligence to do.
And oftentimes we do that
using neural networks.
So TensorFlow lets you do
things like run recurrent
neural networks or
convolutional neural networks.
So let's take a look at
cloud machine learning.
And we've got a pretty
fun demo for you to today.
So as I said before,
it really does span
the spectrum of our platform.
And what does it do?
Well first of all, think
about your own data.
Think about what answer's you
know that your data holds,
you're not quite sure how
to get access to them.
Well, using cloud
machine learning,
you can really extract that
knowledge and understanding
that I was talking about.
You use it when you
have a customized
problem that you want to solve.
It gives you tools for
the entire process,
from ingesting data to
creating and training a model,
and then predicting it's scale.
Now, if you're
familiar with Datalab,
which is built on
top of Jupiter,
you can use it to get the
rich integrated environment
in training and
managing your models.
But what can it do?
Right now, we have
the capability
to perform two primary tasks,
regression and classification.
But what does that mean?
So let's say that you are
running social media analytics.
And for each piece of social
media, you have a few things.
You have the text,
when it was published,
a number of interactions,
the responses, et cetera.
Now, if you used all
of those features
to predict-- like an
efficacy score, how effective
was this piece of social media.
That would be an example
of a regression task.
You use those features
to get a value.
But if you took
those same features,
and used it to tell you--
well the subject of that piece
of social media, that would be
an example of a classification
task.
So let's take a
concrete example.
So let's say, you
were a biologist.
And I say this with the caveat
that I am not a biologist.
And you have a bunch
of images of viruses.
And you want to
automatically sort them
into different classes.
Now, you might be
able to manually look
at all of these images.
And say, oh, yeah that's
strain A and that's strain B.
But it's kind of hard to
develop the criteria for what
makes strain a
different from strain
B. We're actually hampered
by our own ability
to pattern match.
We can't analyze enough.
This is where machine learning
can really help us out.
So let's use this
scenario to dig
into a demo that answers
the question that I
know everybody here
asks themselves, almost
every single day.
"Can I Hug That?"
This is the difficult,
but squishy problem
that we're going to
be tackling today.
"Can I Hug That?"
is a system that
takes an image, it processes
it, and then tells you
if you should hug it.
So for instance, let's
say we have this image
of an adorable fluffy bunny.
You say, "Absolutely,
I want to hug that.
Maybe not too hard, it
looks rather fragile."
So "Can I Hug That?"
would say, "Go for it."
But if instead, I
gave it this image
of a shattered light bulb.
It would say, "Back away slowly.
I'm preemptively calling 911.
Just don't hug that one."
So this is easy for
us to understand,
but it's actually
quite difficult to do.
If you thought about what
makes something huggable,
we would get into
this conversation
of the platonic ideal
of a huggable object,
there's no defining
characteristic.
So what are we going to do.
Well, we're going to
take images that people
have found huggable
or not huggable,
and those are the labels.
And we're going to use
them to answer a question.
Can I hug that?
And get an answer.
Hug or not.
So what do you think?
Is this going to be an
example of a regression
or a classification problem?
Yeah.
It's going to be a
classification problem.
We're going to
train a classifier
to answer this question for us.
So let's go to a demo.
I'm going to head back.
We're going to use
cloud machine learning
to train our classifier.
And then to use it to
predict new images.
Thank you for
switching to the demo.
So we have our example images.
And I have them in my
cloud storage bucket here.
You can see, hug and not hug.
And if I go into them, they
are just good old jpegs.
So I'll show you a
couple of examples.
So in my NOT_HUG category,
I have an image of a cactus.
I have hugged a cactus,
I do not recommend it.
But we also have things like
clouds, in our category.
If I could hug a cloud,
I definitely would.
So what we've done is we've
taken all of these images,
and we've transformed this
data set into something
that CloudML can process.
And that turns it into
a bunch of JSON files.
So if I go into my
data, you can see
these are our JSON-test,
and JSON-train.
If we look at these
JSON files, then we
get something like this.
It gives us the byte
list of our images.
And if we scroll
down a bit, I'm just
going to search because
this is a very large text,
for each image we also
have a label that's coming
from the HUG or NOT_HUG label.
And here we have--
it's telling us,
well, this particular
one is value one.
So of course, we go back and
we say here's our dictionary,
and at value one,
we have NOT_HUG.
So that particular byte
list was for an image
that was of category NOT_HUG.
So once we have
all of this data,
we then can use it to
actually train our classifier.
So I'm going to switch
to the command line,
and I'm going to clear
it again, so as not
to give anything away.
And we've got a simple Python
script that lets us train.
But before I go, I'm
just going to show you
a couple of environment
variables that are necessary.
So first, I've got
a few directories
to find-- where
we're going to put
the output, and a
temporary holding
directory on my local machine,
and where our data actually
exists, our input directory.
And then we also have
our model information.
So we're using a
model that we've
created with CloudML,
called gpc_next,
and we're on version
4 of that model.
So if we do python train.
I'll just walk through
what we have here.
So first we have which model
we're using, the model name.
You can define a number
of different models.
The version that
we're working with.
Where our training files are.
And where our test files are.
Now when you're training a
classifier or any system,
if you do not test and
validate the model,
then it's not really going to
be all that useful for you.
So we're taking 160
images of each category
to train the model.
And then using some to
test the model as well.
We're also using this
hyperparams file, which
goes into what is actually
happening with the system,
and I'll show you
that in just a minute.
Then when we output,
we'll output back
to Google Cloud Storage
in our output directory.
And we'll tell it the
project, and that we
want to run it in the cloud.
So while I kick that off, I'll
show you the hyperparams file.
So this tells us some
information about the network
that we're using to train.
So we know what the
learning rate is,
how many labels we
have, and how many
lay hidden layers we have in
our neural network-- that's 512.
So our training job
has been kicked off,
and we can check
on it using gcloud.
And we've got a lot of jobs.
You can see I was busy
testing the system earlier.
This is the one we
just created, here.
And it's currently running.
We can check on it.
And say, describe this one.
So this one isn't
quite done yet,
training takes a
tiny bit of time.
So I'm going to use one
that I've already trained
on this exact same data set.
I did this earlier today.
Now what I've done is I've
created a simple flask
server that takes an image and
then uses CloudML to give us
a prediction.
So let's take an image.
I'm going to take an
image of an octopus.
We did not train on any octopus.
And I'll show you
what that looks like.
This is that image.
Now, if I click back
that was actually
a pretty fast prediction.
So it says, "Don't hug this.
This is not something
you want to hug."
But let's try something
a little bit different.
We're also we're going
to use another octopus.
But we're going to use one
that is made out of the yarn,
it's been crocheted.
And it looks like this one.
We did train the
model on pillows.
So what's the prediction?
Do you think we're going
to hug this or not?
And yes.
This is actually
something you would hug.
I find this really
interesting, because it's
been trained to neither an
octopus or on stuffed animals.
But it's been able to
accurately predict whether you
would want to hug this or not.
So let's head back to
the slides if I may.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
So that was CloudML.
But maybe you're like
me, and that actually
kind of pushed the boundaries
of your comfort zone.
Let's take a look
at easy API's that
lets you add jolts
of intelligence where
you need them.
So if you do know
machine learning then
you can use cloud
machine learning.
But if you don't, you
can tap into models
that Google has trained over
extensive corporate data.
You don't have to provide
the training data,
you don't have to provide--
to tune any parameters.
It's fully trained and
validated by Google.
One of them has been in
production for a good while
now, and that's
the Translate API.
It lets you tap into those
statistical language models
that I was talking
about earlier.
And the new one, that
you heard about yesterday
is the Speech API.
This lets you pass in just
audio data and a language.
And it will tell
you what words it
extracts from that audio data.
You can get it all at
once or as it comes in.
The streaming mode is
very-- will be very
valuable for real-time systems.
And the Vision API launched into
general availability yesterday.
But we actually launched it
into beta just in February.
You can use it to label images,
identify landmarks, logos,
do OCR.
And what I find really cool
is the sentiment analysis
over images.
We've been able to do that
with text for a long time
but images are a little
bit harder, right.
Sometimes I can't predict
whether somebody's
feeling angry or not.
So all you have to do is
throw it an encoded image
or connect it to Google
Cloud Storage, which is great
if you want to do mass analysis
over a bucket of images,
say maybe our hug data.
And it returns a
label and a score.
That label is what it sees.
And that score is a
number between 0 and 1,
that indicates how certain it
is that that label is correct.
So now I'd like to
introduce David Zuckerman,
he's the Head of Developer
Experience at Wix.com
and he's going to talk
about their experience
with machine learning on
Google Cloud Platform.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID ZUCKERMAN:
Thank you, Julia.
Really excited to be
here today to tell you
a little bit about our story.
How Wix went from not using
machine learning at all,
not knowing anything
about machine learning,
to doing something
very, very powerful.
So like most of you in the
audience, when Julia asked,
"Raise your hand if you're
a machine learning expert."
I did not raise my hand.
Nor would most of the
people that we have
working for us today with Wix.
When I think machine
learning, I think AlphaGo,
I think autonomous vehicle's,
I think "Can I Hug That?"
I don't think site design,
which is what Wix does.
For those of you
who don't know Wix,
we are one of the largest
providers of web presence
on the internet.
We let people who don't know
anything about technology
build really
compelling websites.
I don't think machine
learning here, right.
This is not something that
screams, "Wow, we're really
advanced machine learning."
Not that we don't
do cool things,
but it's not in the
machine learning category.
Unless when you saw our ad
in the Super Bowl of "Kung Fu
Panda", you thought,
"Yeah, so that company--
that company really
knows what they're
doing around machine learning."
So why am I my up here?
Why am I on stage
talking about something
that obviously is not our forte?
To really understand
why I'm here,
and why we're talking to you,
let's talk about Wix's business
model.
This might come as a shock.
I know we're a startup, but we
actually have a business model.
The idea is that we come in,
you let anybody build a site.
And we've let 80 million
people build sites so far.
And we want them
eventually to pay us.
They don't have to,
we're a freemium model.
But we'd like them
to hopefully give us
some money at some point
for either e-commerce
or hosting or one of our
really cool applications.
And something really
interesting happens
here, which is that
as we're trying
to drive them to
convert-- the more we know
about our user, the more
information we have,
the more we can figure out,
the better the experience.
But the more data we
collect about our users,
the lower our conversion
rate is going to be.
And this makes a
lot of sense, right.
If I'm designing a site.
I've come in, I've
added an image gallery,
and I picked out
every single image,
and I really spend a
lot of time with this.
And then we popup dialogue
that says, "Hi, what are you
building?
Tell me about your demographic.
Are you building a music site?"
It really turns off
our users, and it
drops in a lot of cases
our conversion rates.
So we're stuck in this
interesting position where
we want to know more
about our users,
but we don't want to ask.
But we want to convert.
But we can't ask.
And so inevitably
when we sit around,
we always ask
basically, wouldn't it
be great to know
more about our users
without having to ask them.
And there's a lot we can do
in terms of historical data.
We can infer and
we have inferred
that a lot of our users
build e-commerce websites.
Or a lot of our
users are musicians,
and would love a
music experience.
Or hotels-- but this
is all historical.
This is not in real-time.
And it's things
we have to infer.
And in a lot of cases,
it's a human or team
looking at sites
people have built
to figure out what's going on.
And so inevitably, whenever
we're having this conversation,
and I'll admit,
even though I know
almost nothing about
machine learning,
inevitably someone says,
machine learning to the rescue.
This is obviously going to
solve all of our problems.
If we can drive a
car autonomously,
we can definitely learn
more about our users
through machine learning.
And then you get to this little
asterisk that-- basically,
does anyone at Wix know
anything about machine learning?
We don't.
I'm very comfortable getting
on stage telling you this,
we don't know a single thing
about machine learning.
It's not our core competency.
We have other core competencies.
We have other things that we
are exceptionally good at.
We know a lot about scalability.
We serve 35 terabytes of
data every single day.
We hit-- we handle over
2 billion HTTP requests.
During the Super Bowl, when our
ops team was basically really
concerned, "Oh my god.
The commercials going to
air, what's going to happen."
They ended up having
to watch a football
game instead of
doing what they love,
which is putting out fires.
So scalability we get.
We do a really great job here.
User behavior, we have
over 1,000 A/B tests
running in production
at any time.
We analyze this data, we
have giant Hadoop clusters
that manage all this data
to try to gauge what people
are doing historically again.
This is something
we're very good at.
Also HTML editing products,
this is our core competency.
We built four of them.
The current one is
probably the largest React
install anywhere outside
of Facebook or Instagram.
And we've put a massive UX and
usability investment into this.
These are our core competencies,
these are the things
that we hire for, and
that we're very good at.
Machine learning is
not in this list.
We've got some really
great people also.
We have over 250 engineers.
We've gotten to be
relatively good size company.
Over 40 product managers,
over 30 analysts
and data scientists, but not a
single machine learning expert.
We have people that
dabble, we have people
that know what it
is, and know enough
that we shouldn't
get involved in it.
But it's not just that we
don't have the right people.
It's also that machine
learning has been,
and you all know this, has
been a very, very expensive
proposition.
You have to hire
the right people,
you have to hire these experts,
the few people in the audience
that raised their hands.
You have to find them,
you have to pay them.
You have to put in the
investment in the architecture
in the infrastructure.
And you have to
have enough data,
or hope that you
that you can train these
models so that-- eventually
get what you're looking for.
And we're a start up.
We can't necessarily
pay the cost
of spending x amount of
money for all of these PhDs,
plus the money
and the investment
for something that might
not necessarily payoff.
I mean machine learning is still
in that category of science
fiction.
It's still something that
seems out of the grasp of us
mere mortals.
So when we think
about this, when
we think about machine learning
and how we could use it.
We can go back and--
what is our oxygen,
what fuels-- what could possibly
fuel machine learning for us,
even if we were to think
about going down that path.
And for us, it's images.
We have over two
petabytes of images
that our users
have uploaded to us
over the course of
our existence, that's
a lot of data.
And imagine if we could
mine this data for something
interesting, the possibilities
here are basically endless.
We could recommend
similar photos
from Bigstock, one of our
stock photo providers.
We could pre-build sites
for target verticals.
If we ask one question,
"What are you building?"
We could dynamically produce a
website with the right images,
and the web is very
visual, and build the user
a really compelling experience.
We could make it easier
for users to actually find
images in the first place,
which is definitely a pain
point that we've seen.
We could know what our
existing users have built.
And not know in the sense
that we're inferring,
but actually know
what's in these images,
and provide a better
experience either in real-time
or for future users.
So all of this has
been impossible.
There's been no way that we
would think about doing this.
It had been.
So enter the Vision API.
We were lucky enough to get
early access to these APIs.
And we immediately sat
around and thought, OK, we
could do all of these
really compelling things.
But let's not get excited, let's
see what we can actually do.
And so we handed it off to
one of our junior engineers.
And said, OK here's
the API documentation,
you know the system,
see what you can do.
She came back like
15 minutes later,
and we were expecting
two or three days,
and she came back
15 minutes later
and showed off some
pretty amazing things.
To the point that
even before the API
was out of beta, even
before the Vision API was
released to the
public, we started
rolling it into production.
So what do we do?
All of the images that
are uploaded to us,
and these are over two
million daily images,
we extract labels for.
Every single thing that our user
uploads to Wix at this point,
we extract.
We've also taken all over
existing user photos--
everything, all these
two petabytes of data,
including all of the
stock photos that we have.
And we've analyzed all of them.
This is actually
really convenient.
We actually store our images on
Google Cloud Storage, anyway.
So we're on the Google
backbone, we basically
pointed Vision
API at our bucket,
and it went ahead and
did all the other work.
So that means that
all of these images
are now searchable by our users.
A user can come in
when they add a site--
and I'll show you
this in a second--
actually find something.
It sounds so obvious.
Of course, image search.
But image search, when you
really think technically,
what it entails, is near--
has always been impossible.
So we've also added
face detection as well.
So we take-- for every
image that's uploaded,
we take out the faces.
We extract that into EXIF data.
And we are able to add
things like face cropping
all across our platform.
Both in the Wix editor itself,
and also in the media hosting
platform we have called WixMP.
So let's switch to the
demo machine please.
Can I get the switch please?
Thank you.
All right, so I wanted to build
a quick little site to remember
my experience GCP Next.
And I'm not a designer.
I know what looks good, but
I cannot design it to save
my life.
So I did what most
of our users do,
which is to take a template.
And you can see this image of
someone doing yoga on a cliff,
while very beautiful, doesn't
really scream GCP Next,
doesn't really
scream San Francisco.
So I'm going to go ahead and
do what our users would do,
which is change the image.
And we get this media
manager that comes up.
You can see I've
uploaded one image.
It's not even remotely
of San Francisco.
And so let's put yourself
in the mindset of a user,
or any of you who are
coming to do this,
you want an image
of San Francisco.
You'll probably open
another browser tab,
you'll search for San
Francisco, you'll find an image,
you'll save it,
you'll download it,
you'll then reupload it to us.
For a lot of our users,
they're not technical.
This might actually be something
that trips them up to the point
that they will not
continue building a site.
So now let's take
advantage of image search.
So I'm going to search
for San Francisco.
And I get some really
interesting results here.
I have a map that actually has
a pin that says San Francisco.
I have a cable car, I have the
bridge, I have the Golden Gate.
I have a hotel that's inside--
that's somewhere in the city.
These are not just
obvious things that
say San Francisco somewhere.
These are actually really
well analyzed images.
So now from the
user's perspective,
I can decide I
really like this one.
And I can go ahead and
I can add it to my site.
And immediately
something that used
to be incredibly
hard for users just
becomes easy, without
them knowing anything
about what we've done.
Can we go back to
the slides, please?
So the next thing that I'm
going to talk about and show you
is WixMP.
WixMP is Wix's media
distribution platform.
All of the imagery resizing, all
the image distribution-- audio,
video, everything
that we do, and these
are part of that 35 terabytes
of data that we serve every day,
is a service that we resell.
It's a platform as a
service, and it's actually
running on GCP.
Wix is the largest
tenant on this platform.
And this platform also gains
labels and face detection.
Why?
Because we do.
Because Wix does.
Because we're just
calling an API.
And we're pushing this down to
users of our platform as well.
It's one of the powerful things
about platforms and APIs,
right.
You can mix and match and you
can easily give functionality
to anybody down the
chain without really
having to do a lot of work.
So I've shown you
what it looks like,
and you've heard
us talk about it.
But let me show you the code.
Can we switch to the demo
machine again, please?
So let me ask a
different question.
Julie asked before, how many
machine learning experts
do we have in the audience.
How many of you can
call a REST API?
OK, kind of thought that
would be most of the audience.
So here is our from
production code that
does all of the dirty work.
And you'll notice that,
as I walk through this,
we have about five lines
of code that are actually
calling the Vision
API, and the rest of it
is basically Python scaffolding.
So we set the API.
It's very simple.
It's a-- if you want images,
give it our key, which sorry,
I'm not going to
show our key here.
We go ahead and we
pass in an image URL.
And from that URL
or the image data,
we call a built-in
Base64 library.
And we encode the
image to Base64.
Then we get to the really
challenging part, which
is constructing a JSON request.
That tells us which
information we actually want
to extract from this image.
So we decided we want face
detection, label detection,
landmark detection,
and logo detection.
So we're going all
out here, basically.
And in this JSON, we also put
the Base64 encoded image data.
So this is preparing
the request.
And you can see that when
we actually call execute,
all we're doing is
using an HTTP library,
and executing and waiting
for the response, that's it.
There's no rocket science here,
there's no advanced computer
science here, it's
calling a REST API.
And it was that simple to
gain huge benefits, things
that we could not do otherwise.
So I want to show you
one other thing here.
So this is a node
library for WixMP.
WixMP again, is our immediate
distribution platform.
And it's a simple
node API, and all
it does is it uploads
a couple images.
So I wanted to try
something interesting.
So I took this image of
San Francisco in 2005,
it's been here for a long time.
There's no EXIF data,
there's no GPS data,
there's nothing encoded in here.
I wanted to see if
the Image API was
going to recognize San
Francisco, even 2005--
11 years ago.
And Julia and I, before
this, we took a selfie.
Because, of course, you're
giving a presentation,
you have to take a selfie.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to upload both of
these images to the API.
And as you can see, it's
about as easy as possible.
Upload, pass in the
name of the file.
So let's kick off both of these.
Upload SF and upload the selfie.
And in honor of Julia's
should I hug this or not,
I have a little
custom loader that's
going between bunnies and cacti.
I'm sure the classifier would
have a field day with this.
But so what is this
doing right now?
So this is uploading two
images to Wix, to WixMP.
It's taking them and then WixMP,
while it's persisting things
to cloud storage and while
it's extracting and copying,
it's also going ahead
and it's sending it off
to Google to tell us what's
actually in this image.
And let's take a look
at our from 2005 image.
Water, sea, sure.
Landform, bridge, waterway,
Oakland Bay Bridge,
San Francisco Oakland Bay
Bridge, and San Francisco.
It's really fascinating
to me that, OK, sure.
You know, a human might look
at this and say, oh yeah,
it's a bridge.
It's just the Bay Bridge.
But because you have this giant
trained model in the cloud,
it also realizes
water, sea, landform,
and it picks out a little
bit of San Francisco.
If you didn't know that
that was the Bay Bridge,
you'd have no way of knowing
that that was actually
San Francisco.
And then obviously,
for labels, it's
good to see that the machine
thinks Julia and I are people.
And you can see that we've got
a couple of faces from the API.
And if we go to the Wix
Media Platform console,
you can see that we can go
back and forth between turning
on the face detection or not.
Face detection is pretty good.
Also takes our tag here.
If I could go back to
the slides, please.
So we basically, we
did the impossible.
We did-- or what would
have been impossible
even two or three years ago.
We harnessed machine learning,
without really knowing anything
about machine learning.
We now know more
about our users,
without asking them anything.
This is the holy grail
for this kind of work,
for consumer facing products.
And now that we've
gotten our feet wet.
Now that we realize that the
Vision API is within our grasp,
and other APIs are
within our grasp,
and now that we know
that we have enough data,
and now that we know that
machine learning actually
pays off, we're looking
at CloudML as well.
I'd love to put the
"Can I Hug This or Not"
as a hidden feature in Wix.
But we're looking
at different ways
that we can take
advantage of this.
We could see which
layouts people like,
and start auto laying out sites.
There's so much potential when
you harness machine learning.
And the great
thing about this is
it's the democratization
of machine learning.
It's bringing it
down to everybody.
Either from the API side,
if you can call a REST API,
you can use this.
Or the CloudML side, that you
can know a little bit more
without having to
be a researcher.
It's really amazing.
And with that, I'd love to
hand it back off to Julia.
And she will walk you through
the rest of the cool stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIA FERRAIOLI:
Thank you, David.
You're stealing my
talking points, though.
We're going to talk
about that later.
So you really heard
so much about machine
learning yesterday and today.
And we have these easy
APIs that you do everything
from understanding language
to understanding vision
and understanding audio.
We're kind of covering
the range here.
And like David said,
all you need to do
is be able to make an API call.
It's as simple as
it can get here.
And this is really the
year of machine learning.
We're seeing an uptick
in news stories.
We're seeing an
uptick in how people
are making intelligent systems.
I'm always impressed with
what's going on in the industry
right now.
And our machine
learning platform here,
is really just the first
step that we're taking.
So what you saw today,
you saw the easy APIs
that you don't really need
to invest a lot of time
or education to be able to use.
To cloud machine learning that
lets you solve custom problems.
Sophisticated or as simple
as making informed decisions
about whether to hug your dog.
Hopefully you hug your dog.
And to TensorFlow, for people
doing innovative deep learning
research.
Now I said before that
this is a spectrum.
But you can decide
where you want
to fall along the spectrum.
You can self select.
But even then, it's
not a final decision.
If you're like David and
Wix.com and you say OK,
I'm starting with the
machine learning APIs.
I know they can add value
for me and my use case.
Now it's time to invest
a little bit more
time and effort, hire
the data scientist.
You can upgrade or
move to cloud machine
learning to get more and deeper
insight out of your data.
Or if you're working
in research today,
and you've been working
with TensorFlow,
you can use the graphs--
the custom graphs
that you've built with
TensorFlow as models
on cloud machine learning.
You can productionize
your research.
So it's fluid, you
can move between where
you want to follow here.
So with that, I'm going to
leave you with some resources
to get you started.
All of the cloud machine
learning and the APIs
are hosted off of
cloud.google.com.
This is where the
cameras come out.
And TensorFlow is on
tensorflow.org as well as
GitHub.
You can see an example
of image classification
on TensorFlow, with this
TensorFlow for poets link.
And the images that we've used
today are all Creative Commons
and they're linked off of the
gist we showed you earlier.
So David and I will
be in the playground.
The Emoto booth is actually
using the Google Cloud Vision
API in production right now.
So if you want to
chat with us, please
feel free to meet
us there or online
at any of our social channels.
So that's what we've
got for you today.
And we hope to hear
from you and what you're
doing with machine learning.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]